[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
good morning
to all the folks out there who did not
steal 700 pages
top secret classified documents today is
taco tuesday today is texas called
tuesday today is democracy tuesday
so if you're in florida if you're in
oklahoma if you're in new york go vote
engage in your democracy use your ballot
as
as your crutch for democracy
democracy will live on
today we will
see who comes out in the primaries
for florida marco rubio is a little
scared he's terrified he's begging on
foxy's please give me money please stop
giving all the money to trump
stop giving it all to him give it some
of it to me
val dimmings is moving up in the polls
mark kelly in arizona is of course
fetterman's gonna absolutely wipe the
floor with oz
and tim ryan
is
destroying
jd vance
in ohio
and it seems if ron johnson is on his
heels
but the story this morning the story
this morning is
that nara
has handed over the first 15 boxes and
there's over a hundred classified
documents with seven
seven hundred seven hundred pages
that were stolen from us
that the cheeto dust mobster i don't
know what he was going to use them for
it's unclear exactly what these
documents are i can only imagine they
have some sort of value to i don't know
like saudis or something maybe even
russians
it's becoming more and more clear that
he's [ __ ] his lawyers are [ __ ]
he tried to file a motion in some kind
of court it was written in crown
apparently it has no legal standing it's
going to make his case worse
uh even cash patel out there admitting
that yeah i touched him i touched the
documents i seen him and and i was there
when he when he when he did his magic
trick of declassifying them because he
said it out loud and i i heard him say
it i heard him say declassify every
document i've ever i've ever stolen any
document that i've ever stolen he said
to declassify that that's what he said
it is not going well for these people
jared kushner even on fox news this
morning's like i don't know anything
about that [ __ ]
never seen it never heard it i have no
idea
how many people you think are wearing a
wire around this guy
i mean that's a decent question right
how many people
are wearing a wire around this guy i
mean i'm not just talking about law
enforcement
putting a recording device on you would
you would you go around trump in the
same room as him
i mean just even being in the same room
without having a recording device on
hell to the no
no way would i do that
absolutely not
no [ __ ] way would i go
into a room where trump was especially
if it was in a room where he's got an
open safe and he's he's pulling he's
pulling out nuclear codes and [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is going on
i mean we think it's funny and we think
this is you know
good
for our democracy that he's getting
caught up in his crimes
but this is horrible this is horrible
for national security
it's a huge risk
for national security
reality winner got caught with one
document one
one page
and they cuffed her and shackled her
immediately
someone
someone out there owes reality winner
300 apologies
now 700 a thousand apologies i don't
know we keep racking up how many [ __ ]
classified documents this dumb
[ __ ]
stole
it really is
it's it's laughable almost i hate to
laugh about our national security being
at risk
but these people are he's such a dumb
[ __ ]
and all these crimes that he's
committing
he's committing after he's president
that's the other thing i don't i i'm not
sure if people really grasp the
significance of that he always he always
used that he was the president and he
was you know
he couldn't be charged with any crimes
or be indicted he was immune
from criminal charges he did this [ __ ]
after he was president
the other thing that makes me think
about this is
the doj wanting those first 15 boxes and
now they found 300 other pages
my guess was is they wanted those first
15 boxes to see what the [ __ ] he copied
and kept and ended up in the 12 boxes
that they took
the second time after he said no no no
absolutely
we do not have any more classified
documents we gave them all to you and
christina bob his attorney [ __ ]
signed and said yeah i verified that
all those documents we gave to you and
we do not have any other document they
did
i would i would say christina is in big
[ __ ] trouble here
and i wouldn't be surprised if she is
she becomes the next alan weisselberg
that flips on trump
it's not just her law license that it's
at risk here
she's lying on federal affidavits about
classified documents
why in the [ __ ] are the do these people
think
that they're not way out of their league
christina bob apparently when she went
to the federal courthouse the other day
she had to ask where she had to be
because she'd never been in a [ __ ]
federal courthouse before
look when you actually
hire an attorney
sometimes you don't sh you should i mean
most time you shouldn't even have to
like that attorney
you don't care what they look like you
don't care where they're from you don't
care if they really support you
politically not or not
but when you hire an attorney you want
someone who knows what the [ __ ] they're
doing
and normally
normally when an attorney hires a client
because it kind of goes both ways folks
when an attorney picks a client and
takes a case normally
they want that client to be a
a client he is not clienting very well
he sucks at being a client here
which politically is
is good for our side
he's such a dumb [ __ ]
it's not even a competition here
someone who is in the predicament that
he's in would do one of two things they
would do what reality winner did and go
in and make the best possible deal they
possibly could make in that moment or
they would shut the [ __ ] up
and he's not doing either one of those
things
not doing either one of those things
he's [ __ ] he's completely screwed here
and so is his attorneys especially the
ones that are out
admitting to crimes on talent on
television what are you doing
oh
and cash patel
i i believe that's part of the story
that's untold i know that christina bob
story is starting to be told a lot of
people don't know who christina bob even
is she's come out of nowhere here and
the reason why she's come out of nowhere
is because she's one of the last ones
with a [ __ ] law degree that'll even
protect this guy or life for this idiot
the rest of them have either lost their
law degree
or they've abandoned him at this point
but christina bob she was in the war
room on january 6 standing next to steve
bannon rudy giuliani and john eastman
she's a former dhs official under the
trump administration she left the
administration to go to oan the
propaganda machine to prop up trump
inside that propaganda machine
that was the [ __ ] goal that was her
whole purpose
and yeah now she's coming to the
forefront we're learning who she is but
she's been a part of this trump treason
train for a long time
a long time she's been a part of the
trump treason plan
and she's about to find out the way she
[ __ ] around
christina bob
my guess would be that
she's not only going to lose her law
license but she's probably going to be
charged with lying on that affidavit
at a bare minimum at a bare minimum
she'll become a witness
for the government on that affidavit
i don't see how she can't be
it's not going well for them at all
and again
i'm not sure this and i don't know if
there's a copy machine in melania's
closet or not
but i think that's why they wanted those
first 15 boxes they wanted to see how
many of those [ __ ] classified
documents had been copied and kept there
and then they were moving them around
and [ __ ] they saw him on the cameras
again
i say this
he's the cheeto dust mobster and really
a lot of people call him a mobster and
he acts like a mobster but if he really
is a mobster he is the [ __ ] world's
worst mobster
like if you were gonna watch a [ __ ]
movie if you were gonna make this into a
movie
he would be he would be the world's
worst mobster on the movie
and a lot of people are questioning well
why isn't he arrested
why isn't he arrested yet why haven't
they put the guy in handcuffs they got
the evidence it's right there it's clear
as day here's the thing
i actually think the department of
justice is going we're still collecting
evidence on this dummy
he still to this day probably has
classified documents probably still
committing crimes in
an open view of a [ __ ] video camera
that they're probably gonna get
they're probably gonna get that evidence
he's still crying
he's not the president and either that's
a significant part of this
is it doesn't matter what kind of
deluded [ __ ] his supporters say online
rather they believe joe biden's a real
prisoner or donald trump's a real
president doesn't matter he's not the
president and he's not protected by any
kind of executive privilege either
that's the other nonsense here that he
keeps saying executive privilege and
attorney client privilege he keeps
trying to claim these privileges that he
doesn't have you don't have attorney
client privilege when you and your
attorney are committing crimes that's
not a [ __ ] thing that is not a thing
and really this special master request
should have been requested immediately
if he was so concerned about these
privileges
which he wasn't concerned about these
privileges until an actual attorney
probably brought it up to him
and he went oh well then we'll try that
we'll try that story we tried the
planning evidence story which now we
know
now we know he went through the [ __ ]
boxes in 2021
how in the [ __ ] did donald trump go
through the boxes of classified
documents in 2021
before they planted them
how
well that story's now all [ __ ]
[ __ ]
that narrative is [ __ ] [ __ ] we
knew it was because they were saying it
we knew that it was [ __ ] because it
was being puked up out of their mouths
just like now this executive privilege
of turning client privilege [ __ ] they're
puking up it's all [ __ ] [ __ ] this
special master request that rather the
judge grants it or not it's all [ __ ]
it doesn't matter if a special master
goes in
to look at these documents if they have
executive privilege or attorney client
privilege he doesn't have it
he doesn't have it he is not
he is not the president
he's not the president
he doesn't fully understand what the
[ __ ] he did to himself no clue
he doesn't understand that the president
is an office
it's not a person a person holds the
office and that office
is ours
it's our [ __ ] office
it's us
we get to choose the [ __ ] that
is sitting there
they don't get to own anything about
that office they have the privilege if
you want to talk about privilege they
have the privilege to serve us
and i think america's starting to come
around to that i think people really
starting to learn relearn
what democracy is and how powerful it
can be for the people
when we actually exercise our liberty
and we do it in aim to preserve our
liberty
when we do those things like today you
have the chance to preserve your liberty
in florida
and yes it's just a primary you're just
deciding who and what party is going to
be running
but that's important that's [ __ ]
vitally important
that you get to choose who you want on
what side of the ballot rather it be in
oklahoma florida or new york today
and and other states on other primary
days some have already happened some are
going to continue to go
this this stuff is important
these people make decisions
that can affect all of us
just like this stupid bastard who stole
our documents they're our documents
they belong to the office of the
presidency which is our office
not his not joe biden's not barack obama
not george w bush but here's the problem
that we have with the cheeto dust
mobster and he still does not get it it
is clear that he does not understand it
never has and they could not [ __ ]
they couldn't get his
meat mind his hamburger filled head
to figure this out
you
are not
the president
you are the person who is holding that
office and has the privilege of the
people
that office the documents and what
happens belongs to us
you are a servant
to us [ __ ]
just the same way as joe biden is a
servant to us
and i believe that's one reason why joe
biden kicked his ass by 8 million
because the american people understood
that joe biden understood that
that he knew he wasn't a [ __ ] king
that he knew he wasn't a dictator that
he shouldn't be a [ __ ] celebrity
that the reality's
reality show dumpster fire does not need
to be had in the oval office
but clearly the former guy the cheeto
dust mobster grandpa poopy pants still
cannot get that through his thick
[ __ ] skull
that those documents are ours that
office was ours
and when he did what he did
not just on january 6 but was the lowest
of the low but every [ __ ] day in that
office
when he thought it was all about him and
he
he was our ruler
he was only marching towards the day
that would take him down
and he made a huge mistake a huge
mistake
by assuming
that he would always remain president
always remain president
because he really thought a president
can never be charged with crimes it's a
thing you can't ever once you become
brave you can never be charged
which i guess there's some reality to
some
deference that is afforded to
former presidents we see it playing out
right now in the courts
i mean if i got caught
with 700
pages of classified documents
oh i'd be completely [ __ ] you would
not be listening to me on the radio
or youtube or twitch twitter facebook
you wouldn't hear my voice today
so there is some leeway given to former
officials
we watched it if you if you remember
we witnessed it in the
when general petraeus
was caught
mishandling classified documents if you
remember the story of general petraeus
yeah he's the architect
of winning the iraq conflict that's what
they say
but general petraeus was writing a
biography with an author he ended up
having an affair with the woman
but he was using classified documents
that he had legal custody of
but he the problem is is he was leaving
in the custody of her
he was mishandling those documents
and yes because he was a former official
we gave him some leeway
as to explain why
because there are things that happen
with these documents that are legitimate
mistakes
but i highly doubt
that in a court
or in a grand jury that there is going
to be a situation where the former guy
the cheeto dust monster grandpa poopy
pants can convince them
that somehow
he slipped and fell and 700 pages of
classified documents fell into the first
15 boxes
give me a [ __ ] break
and they're only they're only telling on
themselves i believe there was [ __ ]
hidden in her closet melania's closet
why would he also would he bring it up i
believe that cash patel helped him pack
these boxes why else would he say he was
standing in the room when donald trump
you know waved his hands and did a
declassified seance or whatever the [ __ ]
he's talking about
as if as if donald trump just has to
think that a document is declassified
and that's
that's the declassification process
folks it has to be remarked this stuff
was not even remarked it was in its
original [ __ ] top secret
markings then it's classified markings
this is not this
you know
the crazy part is
is that he's still grifting on these
people these people are still giving him
money
and it's because the right-wing media
machine is absolutely diluting these
people's minds of what is really
happening and i guess that's the real
question here
for our democracy
as we think about this as people go to
the polls and wait in line to
engage in their ballot
and do their their duty as a citizen to
this country
to decide who they want on the ballot
today in states like florida new york
and oklahoma
i guess the real question is is how long
will it actually take to break this
fever
because it's not it's not a national
fever really
it's their party's fever
they're the one with the disease
we're just kind of
hanging around in the same vicinity at
this point
because i believe you have the option
you still have the choice as of now as
long as we don't put these fascists into
power you have the option to go save
your democracy you have that option
and yes there's in some states they've
lowered the access they've tried to rig
this vote
and it still appears that they're going
to lose badly
even when they're cheating
and i'm not talking about changing votes
or voting machines or mike lindell my
pillow nazi type [ __ ] i'm talking about
they're trying to change policies to
make it to where you can't vote
because they know the more people who
vote
they know it they know
the more people who vote the more
trouble they're in into hanging on to
their power
so use it
use it before you lose it because this
is the most important election of our
lifetime i've said that over and over
again and i believe as soon as these
votes are counted and certified the next
one will be the most important of our
lifetime because i don't think these
people are going to climb back
underneath their rocks anytime soon they
have not proven that yet
they want to turn this into a fascist
state
they want to make sure that they take
your rights and your liberty away so
they can dictate to you who you can and
cannot be
who your children can and cannot be how
you can and cannot raise them what
religion you can and cannot be
that's what fascism does
and they're at the front door knocking
so it is time it is time for you to
engage in your democracy
one way you can do that is listen here
every single weekday for two full hours
monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter and twitch and
simulcasting from the midas touch
facebook page you can also support
pro-democracy speech today if you'd like
to support our show we love to see your
your support we appreciate all of it you
can go to link below
support.tonymichaelspod.com
or you can use the qr code there in the
corner
or you can go to thetonymichaels.com
just click the links in all the bios
you will get there so thank you for all
your support but don't just support this
pro-democracy speech there's so many
other pieces of pro-democracy speech
that care about our democracy not just
not just care about bashing politicians
but care about our actual institution of
democracy and our form of government
because we care about you
minus touch network we have texas paul
he cares about democracy like a
[ __ ] he's democracy af
over there texas paul we're gonna have
texas paul at the bottom of the hour
it's it's tuesday and you know texas
paul is here to join us
here in just a few minutes
so let's do this let's go to a break
and then we'll bring texas paul in
right after this stick around texas paul
right after this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
[Music]
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome
welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around to the break
we've got the midas mighty favorite
[Music]
the pro-democracy cowboy i don't know if
he calls himself again i'm not really
sure he wears a hat he wears a specific
hat you know him by texas paul but he's
a minus mighty favorite texas paul how
are you doing this morning
man i'm wonderful i am wonderful i hope
my voice isn't too bad cove has been
kicking my ass but i wouldn't miss this
audience for the world man i'm telling
you they would i could be on fire and
i'd just piss on myself and show up i'm
telling you i'm ready
i'm ready i'm i'm glad to have you here
i'm happy to have you here because we
got a lot of stuff a lot of stuff to
talk about today i know um there's a lot
of news and normally we talk texas stuff
but i think i think we're gonna have to
uh maybe skip on the texas stuff today
and talk a little more about some of the
things that are going on nationally um
because there's some happenings in
florida texas paul there's a big
election down there but not only is
there an election
but apparently um news is that there's
700 pages with cheeto dust fingerprints
on it i don't know what do you make of
that story that's developing
well i tell you there's if you don't
mind a little rumor mongering
oh go ahead go ahead really
this is this is okay this is what
happens when you you know people that
are in law enforcement especially
federal law enforcement um
they will talk about stuff like this is
going on i mean this is this is their
job this is this is the highlight of
their years
is a big case like this and boy the
rumors do fly
but there is one that i'm hearing
repeatedly that you know how
mango mussolini likes to
whenever he gets into trouble
he always does something
horrible
to distract from it
i mean have you noticed that as a as a
modus apparently of this [ __ ] well of
course of course
he does something completely horrible to
change the narrative change the
conversation
from what i understand
there is a s
there is a rumor going around that uh
the documents he took
i don't think he really understood how
much trouble he could get into
for taking those particular documents
but he was looking for something bright
and shiny to take with him
because he also took his own
ci files
his own confidential informant files
which were
not returned
well from what i understand
i think he's burying his past
and he was trying
now i don't i can't say i think that i'm
saying this is a rumor i've heard that
i've been unable to confirm at this
point i am trying desperately to confirm
this i really am i'm asking everybody
every federal law enforcement officer i
know
because if you get enough of them to
confirm a rumor it usually is true
um
but yeah i'm hearing that he he took his
own ci file
uh his everything that they had on him
and just ran it through the shredder and
burned it and got rid of it and
and i i don't know exactly what he did
to get rid of it i don't know if he
burned it flushed it down the toilet ate
it what he did with it
but those files never made it back well
he likes he likes to eat he likes to eat
let me let me bring in gabe here gabe's
with us uh gabe have you heard this
rumor that i have not but that doesn't
surprise me at all like what that he's
eating documents or the ci part i mean
like i no if he's if he's getting rid of
his own documents i would 100 percent
not doubt that at all like the guy we
know from maggie haberman is flushing
documents he's eating documents he's
you know
eating his own [ __ ] document like
whatever you know the the cycle of him
trying to get rid of these documents as
much as possible i'm sure he would
totally do that in terms of
getting rid of his own personal files i
mean
any criminal who has access to
classified confidential top secret
information
i would imagine
if they had at their disposal those
documents they would absolutely do that
a criminal acts like a criminal they
will try to expunge remove erase all
records of anything that they've been
involved with
but i do believe that there's probably
backups like they don't just have
physical copies so this this dumbass
thinks like hey i'm gonna i'm gonna
shred all these documents meanwhile
someone's like yeah we've got server
backups right up on backups well you
know that that brings up a good point
because i've been trying to figure out
like
what he would take even like what he
would know to take because
john bolton has been making the circuits
in the rounds and he was standing in the
room on national security meetings john
bolton's like this guy doesn't even know
what the hell he's looking at half the
time because he's not he wasn't
interested like they they assuming he
knows how to read too so well that is
right but they struggled texas paul to
give him briefings we know that but the
reason why they struggled to give him
briefings
i mean he because a lot of the briefings
weren't about him so they weren't
talking about him so he didn't have any
interest in it but they couldn't get him
to read these things like gabe's saying
he probably didn't understand them fully
and and i think the real problem here is
he had no interest in understanding them
like he doesn't give a [ __ ] about
national security what does he give a
[ __ ] like literally they had to convince
him the reason why he cared about
national security because his properties
might be at risk
yeah i mean it's it's it's it is
something he is a narcissistic sociopath
to the extreme
he doesn't give a [ __ ] about his own
family his own look what he did he put
eric's ass in the sling stealing from
eric eric was in control of a charity he
was stealing from eric's charity event
to put in money in his own pocket to go
by
i mean things like portraits of himself
so that
his portrait would sell for high enough
to feed his ego
i mean
it it's
the man is a classic narcissistic
sociopath who really doesn't give a damn
about anyone anything this country his
followers
anything it is always about him look at
the grift since he left office i mean
the man did nothing
but
just rip his
own followers off hey send me money for
my defense send me send me money to
overturn this election when every human
being in his orbit
with any knowledge of this election i
mean any actual professional knowledge
of this election told him he lost
so it was all a gift i mean
he'll take money from anybody look what
he did to his own ex-wife
i mean jesus christ have you seen that
gravesite they put ivana in i mean yeah
well yeah
i wouldn't be surprised if they're
trying to look for you know documents in
that damn casket who knows who knows
what he could have done i mean if he
would because i believe that he probably
stashed this [ __ ] in milan some of this
stuff in melania's closet that's why he
kept saying that right he kept saying
melania's closet melanie's closing
because he's always telling on himself
he's always done that but gabe this
morning you got a text message and you
even posted the uh he's still grifting
this this morning texas paul
um
donald trump donald trump is trying to
he's trying to to sell is it gold cards
is that what this is it was exclusive
the text the text that i got this
morning said exclusive gold card your
offer equals activated friend prez trump
wants you to claim your gold card one
hour claim and then it took me to this
page which is about some
you know cheap plastic card where i have
to contribute 45 dollars to get texas
paul do you want your official trump
gold card do you want no hell no
[Laughter]
look at this [ __ ] this guy i did once i
did once buy a roll of trump toilet
paper that had trump's face on it just
so i could wipe my butt with it i did
buy that i will admit it i mean look if
he if trump was really a grifter he
would he would sell anything that was
pro and against
uh his image you know uh but he can't
because like you said right he is an ego
maniac a narcissist he is a sociopath
like the guy cannot
not think of himself right he always has
to think of himself um you know for the
same reason like he took
he took the the job or uh ran as
president you know no one in that group
no one in that and that uh that campaign
thought he would win that's why on
election night in 2016 nobody could find
him i mean omarosa talks about in her
book it was like nobody could find trump
because no one on that team actually
thought that he had a [ __ ] chance and
then when he did win and when he was
president we find out that he's you know
drawing sharpies an extension of florida
he's asking if he could new hurricanes
he's wanting to send missiles into
mexico and just be like we didn't do it
you know like this is the guy that uh
you know
constantly pushes a red button so he can
get a diet coke like that's the cool
feature of his camp or his
administration this guy is an absolute
idiot
who didn't expect himself to win and
then when he did become president he was
like well i don't want to do the work i
don't want to
i don't want to read the briefs i don't
want to participate in the in the in
these summits these global summits i
don't want to be any sort of
of actual nation
uh that has that has come before in
terms of how we lead his whole thing was
what can i do to make the most amount of
money what can i do to stay in the power
the longest so i make more money and
have more influence like that's all that
the guy is and you're totally on the
point but that's what that's what i'm
saying is in the first in the first of a
block of my rant is that this guy could
only think about himself like paul said
he can only think about himself he he
had no clue and still has no clue that
those documents that he has in those
boxes are ours they're not his they're
not they're not yours dummy just because
they got your name on them or they
happen because you were the president
doesn't make it yours because he doesn't
fully understand what the office of the
presidency is he never did and you can
clearly see that if you go back and look
at his twitter archive when he's
tweeting about obama he clearly does not
understand that the office of the
presidency is not the person it that
person holds that office they have the
pleasure to serve that the pleasure that
we give them as a people
because it's our government but he
clearly does not understand that he
doesn't own those things and i think
that's where he gets it wrong texas paul
when he's bitching and moaning and
complaining about obama he stopped i
think he stopped doing that does he stop
is he's not messaging about that and
stop talking about that and the reason
why is because he knows
[ __ ]
he is 100 consumed by the fact that his
ass is in a slain
i mean he is in full free god man did
you read that idiotic filing that he
made
he's he's representing himself pro se
and suing the united states government
like there's no there's no there's no
specific group department whatever it
just says the us government one because
again
because that's what it is it's one man
against a corrupt government he's such
an idiot well and the other thing too is
he files it in a weird in a weird
district because he thinks i guess he
thinks he can judge shop his criminality
which you can't that's not what happens
you i mean he you can judge shop when
you're bringing a civil case but you
don't get to judge shop when you're
committing crimes like that ain't a
thing that's not how it works at all and
that clearly because he always claims
that he knows courts and he knows
lawsuits
but this guy has never actually been
indicted on federal crimes but he's he's
appearing he's appearing to to get there
very quickly texas law there there's one
the one so last night i went to the the
how we win podcast live show and and
brett and ben oh yeah yeah
and so it was a fun show there a lot of
different people we had you know mueller
she wrote we had uh frangela we had uh
katie griffin um brian tyler cohen but
during during the bit that it was
it was bret uh brett ben and uh brian
tyler cohen and they were talking about
this exact thing right ben comes in he's
like look what he filed is not an actual
thing like it is complete [ __ ] it is
you know this uh this um
this document that he he's like got no
affidavits he's got no actual evidence
he's just like oh look at these things
like they they did me wrong
and then they made this joke of like
nobody knows who this trustee guy is
this uh this lawyer special master is
that yeah yeah well well they they they
ask for a special master which is weird
because it's two weeks after the fact it
would typically be done like wait wait
are you talking about the lawyers the
worst thing that could happen to him by
the way if he got that appointed exactly
oh yeah absolutely because he'd really
be [ __ ] because it would be a corner a
court-appointed master not one he
decided yeah and well he doesn't that's
the thing he doesn't understand that so
but anyway there's this there's a one
lawyer that's listed on the document as
trustee and they made this joke last
night about how you know those the um
the fake personas that trump would have
when he was john barron right exactly so
the question of is this trustee actually
a lawyer or is it just trump
under the name of trustee oh my god can
you imagine if we find out that this
dumb [ __ ]
put a fake look at texas ball he can't
he can't stop he can't stop
he oh we're going
down
oh absolutely absolutely he would do it
this dumb [ __ ] would totally
would totally put a fake name on a
document just to prove that he's right
yeah he's like i got another thing
people are saying people are saying i
don't know who this person is right i
mean we know that no one no one is
taking these cases for trump because
they either know this thing is talk they
they know to stay like 10 000 miles away
because it's that toxic
or they know he won't pay me or they're
just like look this is a [ __ ] mess
i'm not willing to put my reputation at
risk here for taking up this case
and being the the actual like target of
of both sides well but texas no i i'll
yeah
no right i'm sorry i didn't interrupt
you no no go ahead tell us why that's
what i was going to ask is why do you
think no one will take it i mean i
believe that it's because that you're
you're going to have you're going to
have a situation where they're going to
be uh possibly have criminal liability
because he's going to be lying to them
and they're going to be you know filing
briefs based on lies and it's hard to
prove but what's your take
that you can't really get in trouble for
your client lying to you so much it's
not so much that as this is a real [ __ ]
around and find out situation
it really is this is as serious as it
gets
and
if you have a client
that is
as completely 100 percent out of control
a complete narcissistic sociopath who
will not listen to you will not shut his
mouth will not stop doing stupid things
you can literally find yourself in not
not in legal trouble right with the
judge but you can literally find
yourself
in in situations in a courtroom that are
just humiliating
and that is the one thing that these
lawyers cannot have is i mean they live
and die by their legal reputations right
and to have to stand before a judge and
say well your honor um
we were
not able to complete your order to
produce documents because my client
isn't cooperating with me
and i can't make my client cooperate
with me
so uh sorry
and then
they look like complete [ __ ] idiots
to the entire world right well nobody
wants to prefer that fool anymore right
well because they're rep like you said
their reputations are hanging on this
right and that's why that's why
christina bob is in such a [ __ ] mess
here and i believe uh she's probably
gonna end up being a cooperating witness
with the government because she's
signing affidavits as an attorney that
are [ __ ] fraudulent and and and i i
forget who i was listening to yesterday
i think it might have been glenn
kirschner was making that point um that
yes christina bob is in a lot of trouble
here but the really the trouble that
christina bob is in is going to totally
transfer
to donald trump because
they're going to prove actual cust
actual possession
of these documents right so i think
that's important too because there's two
types of criminal you know possession
there's actual possession where you're
holding it in your hand and then there's
there's constructive is what they call
it so constructive is where it's
reasonable to believe that you would
have possession of these documents in
other words if there's a box of
classified documents in your wife's um
you know closet
it
and you have access to that closet
it's reasonable to believe that you have
constructive possession of those but i
think it goes well beyond that because
i just i'm trying to get inside of when
i've watched donald trump on camera when
he's when he's done this [ __ ] before in
the past you you listen to like stormy
daniels talk about how he he got her to
do what he got her to do
it just feels like at some point there's
gonna be some um
closed circuit television where donald
trump is in a room
bragging with someone who has
not only no business seeing the
documents that are quote unquote his
because that's what he believed but
actually it is it is
could be a crime
to show these people who do not have the
clearance to look at these documents and
he's going to be bragging and holding
them and and ho like he does he holds
everything up he's like look
look it's it's fake but i think it's
real i'm holding it up so it must be
real right and i think that really
is gonna be the harpoon in this guy's
ass what do you think paul
yeah there's already been some
normally the doj doesn't leak like that
i mean they really don't they're really
really good about keeping this stuff
under lid uh it doesn't matter what the
press says or thinks or how it's going
in the press it matters how it's going
in the courtroom but there has been
uh
a few drips coming out that
you're talking about
closed circuit
footage
where
people are going in and out of the
storage room where some of the most
sensitive documents were kept in and out
of the basement where they found i
believe they found some
compartmentalized uh uh
level documents down in the basement and
there were people just constantly going
in and out of that basement had that had
access to these documents and
so yeah and that's what we know so far
and believe me they're not giving us the
crown jewels in in a leak they're not
um i'm i'm very surprised that leak
happened
and uh
i i think some
honestly if i had to speculate and guess
um
fba fbi agents are people they're very
very very very very professional but
when he started doxxing these agents
yeah
he pissed somebody off and i think
somebody with some knowledge
really said okay you want to leak
[ __ ] let's do this let's do this
i can hurt you real bad well and i think
that's that's another uh
storyline of this is that he's really
not just going to war with the
government like we were talking earlier
one man versus the government he's
really going to war against um law
enforcement here where he claims he back
the blue and he loves law enforcement um
because let me tell you something when
you start when you start uh turning on
law enforcement not just fbi
uh law enforcement have their own little
little community and they have their own
little club as it were and we all know
that with some of the cases that we've
seen
um from around the country where and
one most prominent in our memory right
now is the three officers in arkansas
who have been suspended um for beating
the hell and damn near trying to kill
someone because i don't know they i'm
not sure exactly what happened but they
had him on the ground pounding his face
on the concrete continued to assault him
uh even after he was the three of them
were on top of him and he was detained
um they continued to beat the the the
suspect regardless of what he did
and what you know regardless of what the
charges were
so they have this own little tight-knit
community that they protect themselves
and i think you're right paul that
culture is going to hurt
um donald trump here as he goes to war
with them because it's not just about
the the government or the deep state
anymore he really is trying to throw
law enforcement itself under the bus by
his statements and his actions um
and i i believe that's gonna be to his
detriment back to the uh the leaking
um of the the description of the closed
caption or the closed circuit television
um gabe you you have
you have uh uh unearthed some of these
unboxing videos yeah there's and there's
still videos to come right but what do
you know more about um some of this
leaking that's coming from the the
closed circuits television because
actually
that is the most the most that i'm
interested in is to actually watch
because i believe at some point in the
near future and it might not be within
the next year but maybe the next two or
three years we are going to see footage
of the former president united states
in a room with a bunch of people holding
up classified documents so he can prove
that he had them but what else on the
closed circuit television do you think
we see because don't they have like six
months or something like that right and
it just and from what i'm seeing now
they also uh a doj has subpoenaed
further surveillance video of mar-a-lago
which means that i don't you know i
don't know if that that it covers a
different portion of the
property or if that's even further back
from the six months so because like
every day every day in the last two
weeks like and i'm working on what was
that but every single day there's new
there's like a new [ __ ] bit to add to
where i'm like i don't know
when do i have to when i need to cut
this off and be like look
dvd on the rest of this stuff because
it's just gonna get worse but like you
look at what's happening every single
day
it is some new thing that happens right
yeah but it seems like it's every couple
hours not even oh no i mean
i mean like even even yesterday we find
out it's 300 documents just from those
15 boxes or so and then trump's lawyer
puts out this you know on his own
website then we find out there's 700
documents
or three sorry 300 from the the the
august the second round the second round
700 from the first round like we're like
all right we're already at a thousand
documents like who knows what was
destroyed so how many were actually
taken beforehand but on the question
about the cctv footage
i have to imagine what we've at least
what we've been told so far what has
been leaked is like
the day
the day in question of the original
handing off and signing of the by the
lawyers to nara to say you guys have
everything that's what we have been
that's that's what has been leaked to
say we have footage of that event and
also
uh representatives of trump moving boxes
after indicating that they had some that
they've given everything away so that
right there is already like that's
if if it wasn't already a smoking gun it
definitely is
wasn't one guy like standing on like a
balcony
right so that's kind of what yeah
they're the details they're the details
of literally like i joked
i joked with tony uh last week about how
this felt like a 1980s like babysitter
like comedy where like the parents
are coming home and the babysitter or
[ __ ] running like they just threw a
party and now they're like sweeping
everything under the rug and like
throwing it out the back so that so the
living room looks clean like that's what
it feels like where it's like this
perfect crossover like we're signing off
and we gave you everything meanwhile
there's a dude in a balcony behind a
curtain that's like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] and
all you can see are his feet right so
weren't they but weren't they also
didn't they also they said that they
were moving documents from like one
container to another right exactly but
also like mix these documents like
like like he was almost trying to be
like oh these are the really these are
the ones that the saudis are willing to
pay a lot of money for right and we want
to make sure that when nara comes back
or the fbi comes back we want to make
sure we stack those in the ones that
aren't that valuable so they can't find
them it's almost like he's putting like
a monet monetized value on each one of
them yeah he definitely i think you know
i think there's definitely a few stacks
of like and not important could be
important definitely important right and
those are things of how he's like not
worth any money maybe some people might
value this and this is definitely worth
a lot of money and so when you ask about
cctv footage like there is that one
which has already been leaked because i
think what happened is you know you made
a good point of these these uh federal
agents their information was revealed
and somebody was like [ __ ] this [ __ ] and
they leaked to the extent of
to say and and hint at we have footage
of you breaking the law
and withholding documents after
disclosing that you did have them and
you handed them off so just know that
this is the least amount that we have we
have one moment and here's a little
snapshot in terms of like describing it
so i can imagine they have plenty more
now the other thing is you know we've
talked about like what took them so long
you know right like i don't think it's
just cctv footage but it's the the i
think that we have had an informant or
someone inside that was able to actually
right
that was able to witness or confirm that
documents were being shown and their you
know photos may be taken and you know
bragging and and and gloating about
having these classified documents i
think what we actually you know in this
time of like
people are like oh what took it so so
long we find out that in january and may
is
that's the fbi was just able to get
these documents recently so i think also
there is someone on the inside that has
verbally confirmed and possibly through
video actually watching trump say hey
check out this document right like look
at this look at this thing i take a
picture take a picture i almost i want
to i want to put money down and bet that
somebody has actual like a button cam or
a lapel pin ram of him actually doing
this crime so i think
you got cctv footage of the whole
property this whole interaction of like
hiding boxes behind a curtain on a
balcony while the while nara is there
you know i also feel like there's also
uh
you know uh
because of proximity there's probably
other things that were captured inside
as well like this whole like basement
with the two padlocks or whatever the
locks were like i'm sure maybe maybe
bodies are going in and out right
exactly i got a question here
is the one that got me in the what
the pool room
is what do you mean like where the pool
equipment is yeah yeah you didn't hear
about that they had these documents
stored in a storage room just off the
pool
now
you mean like like the private pool the
public part of the pool the public what
the [ __ ] are you [ __ ] me there's
room for
chlorine and everything else and they're
trying to say oh yeah well it was secure
they had boxes of documents and do you
know how many people went inside that
room to get i don't know
i can only i can only see the image i
can only see the image of like a like a
a christmas decoration
like a rubbermaid tote that that's
sitting there with trump's handwriting
with a sharpie it says grandpa's stuff
and then it's sitting underneath like a
couple buckets of chemicals and [ __ ]
like well christina bob was on was on
laura ingraham and basically revealed
that she was like so who had access to
this room and she's just talking about
this one room a couple specifically she
goes well you know i mean like maybe a
couple i would have to confirm but it
sounds like like the more and more she
talked the more and more she was
revealing that like oh yeah like only a
few people look at like a handful of
people so like yes there was a lock but
then we put another lock on there it's
like okay one
people have had access despite the fact
that it's under guard by security right
and keep in mind who's regarding it
christina bob give me exactly but also
let's not forget the fact that in 2019
we had a woman
who was caught carrying uh cell phone
devices had oh you know chinese national
right exactly that it's like who's this
woman she wasn't staying there she had
other stuff in a hotel nearby right uh
ca eight thousand and ten thousand
dollars in cash four passports uh a hard
drive a thumb drive uh she had taken you
know uh uh mobile phone you know devices
um
those are the things where you're like
how secure is it it's not secure
especially when you've got [ __ ] eric
trump taking a photo and and showing the
internet
club right well here's yeah here's a
question um from from someone on
facebook texas paul and i want you to
answer because i think i think jody's
trying to be smart here i'm not really
sure if she's serious about this
question
or she's trying to be smart here the
question is
who's the victim are you serious jody
because if you're serious we'll answer
this but i think you're trying to be
smart here
that that somehow no one is the victim
here and yeah we're poking fun at this
because this guy's such a [ __ ] idiot
but but texas paul can you explain to
jody because i think you could probably
do a best who is the victim here and why
is it so [ __ ] important that people
understand
why this is not a victimless crime this
is not
sure jody i can explain that to you you
need to understand when
one of the big problems with this
investigation is when you start at the
beginning first of all
compartmentalized level
documents are not something that are
you know the this isn't hollywood this
isn't the west wing where somebody says
i want to see documents on that no it
goes through a series of requests
they request it
it's the written request is
taken to an archive the archive
brings it to them that's highly secured
it goes to a skiff there is a skiff in
the white house this information
contains
information where you can
glean techniques you can glean uh human
intelligence sources you can glean all
kinds of information off of this believe
me if the chechens can can
can send a a
you know a celebration photo
from the ukraine and the ukraine can
geo-locate their location and kill them
all with a rocket
believe me
there is information they can glean out
of these documents they can
they'll know where information came from
your sources will be burned
our techniques will be burned so we
won't be able to use them again
this is the kind of information that's
just basic this that's the basic that's
before you start talking about the
subject matter now
he is talking about secret
compartmentalized information on nuclear
weapons
do you know how old the technology is on
nuclear weapons
i mean you got
not very bright people in
very well
advanced countries that are main base
acute nuclear weapons this is not this
is old technology
for this to be new enough technology
that it has to become you know
classified
this is some very dangerous [ __ ]
this is next level this is like
comparing gen 5 fighters
to a [ __ ] corsair that you saw on
baba black sheep okay
these this this is beyond next level
weaponry and [ __ ]
has them in a goddamn
pool storage room
coming in and out in a christmas tote
holy crap this went sideways quick it
sounds like jody was responding in the
comments to someone else and i apologize
but i just seen the question there it
sounds like jody was responding to uh
some trump or on facebook here which is
fine we we welcome all sides here to
come listen and to get in some knowledge
here but jody was responding to someone
i think who who was as saying trump is
the victim here of course we know that's
[ __ ] laughable at best but i'm glad
you explained though why this is so
important because i think the american
people must understand that this is so
important that to know that the national
security risk here
is not just detrimental to our entire
country but there are folks out there
that that are human beings they're real
people who who are trying to keep us
safe who he is putting in danger if he's
showing these to people having them
exposed in the pool room as paul is so
jody i'm glad you asked the question i
misunderstood it me too so thank you for
being in thank you for being in the chat
um everyone trying to uh uh apologize to
jody it's an important it's an important
subject right no it's an important it's
an important it's an important issue um
i misunderstood what she was asking she
was asking is
a trump supporter who's the victim with
trump and it's because trump's the
victim here
but it goes to the question you asked
earlier before i came on about how
you know when are we going to see
actual legal action take place
you know it you're talking about this
investigation is going all the way back
to the white house
and and and
you've got to understand there's a
person that that knows i mean they are
highly trained they know they are the
person that ha that signs out for the
document
they carry
their little binder to this gif
they hand it over
to a person that's qualified to receive
it they know that that person has the
credentials to receive it
and then that person doesn't just go on
about their business
this is their meaning for being
for the next till they get that little
document back in their hands
and they can check it off i got it back
yay
and turn it in
this is a very very serious moment in
their lives this is no joke people and
they want to find out
why how did somebody take these this
level of documents you're talking about
this is
this is not a joke people this was very
very very serious [ __ ] he took
getting it out of the white house
was a big deal you know people watch a
lot of tv and think okay
now the president can do anything you
know well no he can't he can't he works
for us there are
even rules for the president
and and they want to know
from the get-go
how why did he request it
how did he get the hell out of the white
house
you know somebody was supposed to snag
this back from him
why did it not go immediately up the
chain of command and somebody start
investigating where the [ __ ] is this
document
that failed
or it was intentionally crushed which is
a crime
right i mean there there is so many
layers to this onion it it
and they're running up against the
election
they don't want to do this
well don't you don't you don't you
believe to some extent that that's why
we haven't um
we haven't witnessed indictments yet
that the department of justice is still
collecting evidence they understand that
this is an ongoing investigation they
understand what the what it could look
like if they were to bring indictments
now
um without a grand jury actually
bringing those indictments and i'm sure
they've already got some of this
evidence in front of grand juries the
doj just received the first 15 boxes
that nara took
a while back but i guess the one thing
that i keep saying
is
and maybe we should uh texas paul i
appreciate you joining and maybe we
should we got to get to the shitless
round up here soon but i want to ask you
do you think anyone who goes around
trump like even the people that work at
mar-a-lago surely they're wearing
recording devices at this point like i
mean you wouldn't want to be within a
thousand feet of this guy without
wearing a recording device at this point
just because
he's so off the chain
that it it i mean you just you want to
have receipts for this criminal i mean
at some point he has to understand that
he's completely [ __ ] here and these
and there's probably more than just one
informant and there's one more than one
person turning on him
my bet is its secret service
my bet that their primary informant on
the documents for secret service secret
service has
a unwritten rule that they see here in
evil
hear no evil but when [ __ ] gets serious
enough they are federal agents
and
i think things just got bad enough that
secret servers had to say okay
we got to call somebody i really think
that's why there was the cooperation at
mar-a-lago with the fbi and the
department of justice and nara you think
that's what part of it
and i think that's why they knew exactly
where everything was
i do
well because because that's the thing
about it mark meadows wouldn't know if
it's mark meadows he wouldn't know where
trump is moving [ __ ] to
and he wouldn't know
okay there's cct
tv cameras that's secret service
that's secret service that knows all of
that
i mean he he trump just went so far that
secret servers had to say
[ __ ] you man you're a traitor i mean
really it it it had to be i'm i i could
be wrong and i'll eat my hat if i'm
wrong but i i guarantee you it's it's
it's
the only the only other possibility
would be
a family member you know like who else
would be close enough like those those
could be the only things because the
other thing too is like you bring up
cctv like even though they knew it was
there nobody tried to get rid of it like
nobody tried to say like oh [ __ ] we got
to go back
you know from the beginning of time of
when we left the white house and entered
mar-a-lago to delete it
um so part of me is like maybe someone
didn't have access maybe somebody maybe
they're all dumb enough and they didn't
even think about that right like you
know but you made a good point on a show
a while back that that maybe that the
cctv is because of secret service
because they're right well yeah exactly
so like yeah when we were trying to
protect him and right right i mean like
as a yeah as a former president you know
first uh you know the president or first
lady whoever you are depending on status
you know there's going to be you're
going to have secret service that is
attached to you at the hip for the rest
of your life right you're gonna make
sure that you wouldn't just put somebody
in a random area and then say well you
know hopefully they they survive right
like you're gonna make sure there's
cameras and you know they're tracking
them and they're watching them and doing
this and doing that so
you know if it wasn't there before he
moved in it was definitely put in after
you know and it's one of those things
where it's like you probably have
um some security official that comes in
and says this is what you need you need
to make sure that it's secure despite
the fact that their wi-fi password is
one one one two two two three three four
four four five you know like it's it's
so it's that dumb where it's like hey
here's the here's the guest password and
you might be able to access the secure
network by just piggybacking off of this
one right so that's crazy [ __ ] it's it
is one of those things where they're
like hey make sure to change this
password make sure to do this and
they're like yeah we'll do that and then
they're like okay and they don't do it
right
and so i wouldn't i wouldn't be
surprised if you know they had some sort
of
security agency that came in and said
whether a secret service or someone else
that said this is the protocol you have
to follow you have to put these cameras
in you have to have it on a secure
server you have to have it stored here
you have to have you have the backups go
here
and maybe you know it's also the other
thing too is like maybe because the
certain protocols in place they weren't
able to dispose of you know cctv footage
because it's backed up somewhere else
right not just mar-a-lago i don't know
if it's safety if it's security texas
paul we're going to go to the [ __ ] list
round up here but give us give us a
shameless plug anything you want to plug
go ahead and tell the audience here now
while we got them where they can find
you and what else you want them to look
at
well i tell you guys i mean if you
wouldn't mind head over to
texaspalmers.com i could really use the
help we're getting we're heading into
the uh
to the last push to the election and any
support you could give us really really
really really helps it helps to pay for
all the great commercials in there and
they're you know union made in the usa
fantastic quality
go take a look at it that way when you
go to a better rally or anything like
that you can represent i sure would
appreciate it
um
guys i really have enjoyed it and thanks
for putting up with the frog voice
as usual i love it and i love your
audience i do want to make a challenge
to your audience because i've challenged
all of my audiences to the same thing
on this subject that you're talking
about
somebody give me because the right
wingers want to have all these different
[ __ ] arguments about it it was
declassified it was they said they
always wanted this cuts through the
[ __ ]
somebody give me a good reason
he had these documents
period i i think that's going to be a
tough challenge and i think that's the
challenge that donald trump no one has
yet i don't know i mean they did say
that
let's see we've heard mementos
scrapbooking and a memoir so
i'm not sure how any of those things
justify having classified top secret
skiff documents you know well i'll tell
you one thing it sounds like secret
classified documents are used to make
sure the ph level in the pool is captain
jack texas paul thanks for joining us i
really appreciate it come back next
tuesday we love having you here everyone
stick around we'll be back with a
shitless roundup right after these
messages don't go anywhere thank you
texas paul we'll see you soon my friend
thank you guys yeah
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capitol have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa don't delay and
get your part and blanket today for just
99.99
actual parting's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
oh jody over on
facebook i want to apologize again to
jody getting her comments confused there
i know i know i know
jody i'm i'm very excited i'm glad
you're one of the finest money and i'm
glad you're in the chat and i'm glad
you're going after the trolls over there
on facebook keeping them in check
i mean we don't try i mean our
moderators are great we've got three
great moderators here on youtube
we have we have midas robin minus margie
and mj they do such a great job on the
chat everyone give love to
our moderators over here on youtube but
we really we don't have control over on
facebook because we simulcast over on
the mighty touch facebook page we do the
best we can
we absolutely do and jody again i'm very
sorry for getting your comment confused
but i'm glad you asked the question i'm
glad we actually
answered that question because i think
that is a question that these boneheads
out there are going to continue to ask
is oh well what's it matter if you had
classified
who gives a [ __ ] it ain't it doesn't
affect you it doesn't affect us it
doesn't it
because i think that is going to be the
talking point so jody again i'm i'm um i
want to tell you sorry for um
misinterpreting your comment there
so we love we love having anyone and
everyone who wants to have a an actual
discussion here on the tony michaels
podcast yeah i mean that is definitely
one of the things that i've seen the
most in uh
in your comments or in my comments on
post especially as they relate to the
documents right like oh you're finding
out cause you posted something about 300
and anyway yeah so yesterday i posted
saying that he had 300 documents right
it was the most recent kind of uh
kind of bombshell that we learned which
was like oh it wasn't just uh it was
like 11 sets of documents and these many
boxes but it's like oh it turns out it
was 300 [ __ ] classified documents
that he had now it's 700 pages right now
it's 700 in the first set of the right
right right so it you know
it is one of the things that i've seen
the most i saw people on like i rarely
look at my comments and i rarely will
look at um
like quote tweets but when i
occasionally do i'll catch in like real
gems and i sent you a couple this
morning which was like
um
gabe is
uh in quotes repeating or repeats or
whatever they say you repeat
they're like gay people repeats in
quotes which i'm like so i then i don't
repeat like they're using quotes the
same way that trump uses quotes right
around it's very strange because you can
quote something that someone's saying
right right or when you're doing the air
quote thing around a word right right or
like
or
because he was doing this on twitter
like the first time he's freaking out
he's not doing it so much anymore we
made a video oh you mean social
what did i say you said twitter
oh jesus christ no i mean they are they
look do look very similar i mean true
social is a copy of twitter someone
someone yesterday was asking me they
were like
do people who post on on twitter his
comments
they were saying this to me in real life
these comments
they can't do that i'm like i do it all
the time i said we even make fake ones
sometimes i mean fake fake yeah yeah
ones fake fake ones
are real ones yeah depending on i think
yeah depending on who you are and how
serious you take it it could be real or
it could be fake right you know but you
can post and i here's the thing is i
truly believe that there are some of his
his statements that he's he's dumping
and puking on fraud social over there
right i actually believe that some of
them are newsworthy now i make them
light and i try to make a joke about
them
in the tweet but
i when i post something like that he has
said over there i actually think like
hey he's telling you something here like
this is this is important when he's
posting [ __ ] about he's reposting a
video of himself to make him look like
rambo or something or he's posting that
he's that he's endorsing some candidate
somewhere or some god-awful person some
vile piece of [ __ ] somewhere i don't
think that's really newsworthy as far as
that goes but when he is telling on
himself inside of a post i think that's
important for people to see you can't
look away you got to know how they're
trying to steal our democracy right to
save it that's important i mean like
we've got you know it's i see someone in
the comments i wrote those documents
were classified
it come out okay well grammar uh it come
out now that joe biden reclassify them
to make them illegal it is a witch hunt
it is a way of the democrats to go after
donald trump the democrats weaponized
the fbi to go after political opponent
medical opponent
uh uh this is going to backfire them
condemn we need to vote is them all out
and are start arresting its crooked
democrats and the crooked fbi agents
starting with garland that's one
sentence just so you know that is one
sentence there is no comma there is no
period there is no exclamation point and
that is one complete statement
trump's watching this and he's typing
who knows
but something like this that says those
documents were declassified it
it came out i imagined what they said so
now it's byton's fault right so now joe
biden reclassified them
i highly doubt that joe biden said
listen listen gabe if if that's the
truth that if the truth is that the
president united states gets to have a
magic wand to declassify and classify
any documents he wants then joe biden
can most certainly do that if donald
trump hey look bonehead in the comments
if donald trump acts which is not true
actually had the power to declassify
just because he thought it with his puny
little brain then joe biden has that
power you dumb [ __ ] and the
reason why that you people don't get it
donald trump doesn't get it it's the
person that is in the office
is not the [ __ ] president yeah
they're but they hold the office of the
president you have to understand that
you have to understand that they only
hold those powers for when we tell them
that they can for how long we tell them
and right now joe biden holds those
powers he's the one holding our office
of the president we
we the people are actually the president
that's our office we just placed someone
there to make those decisions for us you
dummy and let's not forget let's not
forget that when this whole idea of like
oh they were declassified let's go back
to what was originally said when this
search happened it was planted so they
planted declassified documents is that
what you're saying you're saying that
they planted declassified documents that
they have now confirmed that they had
behind a couple locks in a door in a
basement you're you're going to tell me
that now you're telling everyone that
they had the documents but those
documents were not all of the documents
that were there because some of those
documents were new documents that were
planted to make it seem like they had
the documents the whole
time in a basement in other places like
off the side to a pool like is that what
they're saying they're saying that these
were classified but then they're
declassified when they're reclassified
and they're declassified and they're in
a basement and they're on the patio and
they're used as tableware like what the
[ __ ] man well let me tell you something
let me tell you what it is doubt me
doubt me that these were weren't
classified or that he had some sort of
power doubt me and speaking of doubt
mean gabe we got doubt me shirts
there's coffee cups there's a hoodie and
there's a sticker so go to
store.thetonymichaels.com everyone's
been dying for the
for the doubt me merch so here it is it
is live folks on
store.thetonymichaels.com
go
find the perfect doubt me merch
that you'd like to uh make sure your
friends know doubt me about what i'm
saying
because i'm telling you it's gonna it's
easy to know who these things are
yeah i would just say doubt me that
president trump
has or doesn't have executive privilege
with any of these [ __ ] documents he
does not he does not have that he cannot
just say oh i've got executive privilege
just the same way he can't just cast a
[ __ ] sharpie over some documents say
right you classified right well because
you know it's the person who actually
holds the office who holds the power of
the executive privilege now a current
president can say that former president
does have executive privilege in this
office and i
as the holder of this office say so but
it's that president that gets to say so
and with that let's do this because man
there's a lot of video i want to show
and i'm glad we had texas paul here but
we have a short [ __ ] list roundup today
so let's get to it let's start the
countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome to the [ __ ] list roundup
where we round up all the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends there's elections
today one in florida for the primaries
gabe someone's freaking out in florida
have you seen this video of martial
marco
rubio give me your bible first baby give
me a bible verse
too bad he didn't too bad he didn't get
donations for each bible verse he tweets
out let's listen to marco cry i mean
this is the sweetest tears magatears and
i've tasted in a long time let's hear it
she's raising all these small dollar
donors on act blue and god knows where
the money's coming from from all over
the country
i need people to help me but she's
raising all this money from all these
ultra liberals who want to ruin florida
by the way so i do ask people to go on
my website marcorrubio.com and please
give wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait hold on
yeah wait this reminds me this is almost
identical what lindsey graham to lindsey
graham yeah they're attacking me they're
coming after they oh my god guts there's
people in this country that that don't
want me to be a senator that are
donating to my opponent legally on act
blue how dare they how dare they what do
you are this is so stupid this is so
stupid this is obvious what is going on
val demings is starting to really come
to the forefront here in the polls marco
rubio is getting [ __ ] terrified he's
going on fox news to big the fox news
viewers
to give him donations because val
dimming is kicking his ass because
people in this country who have a
[ __ ] brain know that this idiot
shouldn't be anywhere near the
government
anywhere near it he's such an idiot what
a bonehead let's finish while you're
looking up that lindsey graham clip
by these far left marxists uh who
continue to give her
far left does he know what a marxist is
no
does he know that a marxist wouldn't
actually probably donate to a political
campaign like this does he know that
it's
tony they they don't it's woke it's left
it's it's uh we went through this
yesterday
mean anymore i mean i don't like i
understand what woke meant like six
months ago or a year ago like i
understood it then i don't really get it
now like what they're trying to say
they don't even know what they're trying
to say i understand it
like what what the hell like it's trying
to figure out what they mean by
conservative like what do you mean
conservative anything you do is not what
you're doing is not conservative do you
know what that word means it's like um
what's the the um the prince's pride the
line from the princess oh yeah he's
using that word
you don't know what that word is i don't
think you know what that word means
let's let's finish up a little marco
here you know 50 bucks a month or
whatever a week and she's raising a lot
of money but she did it by turning her
back on police officers
oh
marco rubio is now now she's now he's
against people who turn their back
on police officers it's almost like
there's a certain party in this country
it's like back the blue and then they're
like no [ __ ] the blue they're coming
after me because i don't like when
police officers actually do the thing to
me that i want them to do to other folks
right there really stupid well of course
it's it is they will play the victim
at every single turn because they feel
that they have been
violated and they are the real person
who
uh who's innocent right it's it's that
that projection to say
oh no no no i i don't deserve this guys
this is unfair treatment it is clearly a
coordinated attack these people are
trying to push me out
blah blah blah blah blah blah speaking
of victim speaking of victim here's lady
g
let's hear him crying his tears now
you're saying you're saying that marco
rubio lifted this script and he went on
i'm saying that they use the same speech
writer
let's listen my opponent will raise
almost a hundred million dollars ainsley
here i can give you here let me pause it
i'll give you a better version well here
i can i may be able to turn it up here
and sorry about that and it didn't do
let's see if this helps this help money
there we go in the history of the state
my opponent will raise almost a hundred
million dollars ainsley in the state of
south carolina the most money ever spent
in the history of the state on a senate
race was by me in 2014 when i spent 13
million he raised six million dollars
from the time justice ginsburg passed
away within 72 hours and god bless
justice ginsburg we're celebrating her
life i appreciate waiting to saturday to
announce the replacement but i'm being
killed financially this money is because
they hate my guts
he he failed to use the word i have to
yeah he didn't speak writer the
speechwriter is getting better well yeah
yeah they they had to switch it up you
know they knew what buzzwords to go
after but
it is one of those things where it's
like these sound ver as soon as you
started playing because i had not seen
it yet but as soon as you started
playing it it sounded very similar to
the way that lindsey graham felt like he
was under attack all right and he was
the victim oh we're we're under attack
here speaking of victims here's another
one jared kushner oh god look at that
look at it dude his the way he doesn't
look human is that how he doesn't look
human if anyone's running how robots and
ai i mean look look at his hands look at
his hands right he's got his hands like
this right his hands are like this
sitting back like you know great posture
for
is he sitting plugged into the seat is
he
like you know he's being you know he's
he's like the little rom's doll or the
the brahms dolly little boy you know
very weird very
very
he's only you know what he almost looks
as robotic as ron desantis did when he
was standing up with his arm oh yeah
yeah i might show that i might i might
show that picture but let's let's see if
he even moves at all other than just his
mouth and like his neck
let's see let's see in this clip because
uh steve ducey here is he almost gabe he
almost appears to be a journalist like
oh he's almost there almost there and
then he backs out let's watch he's
asking for a special master and asking
for them to stop going through the stuff
as they may be right now uh the new york
times has got the android is getting
very nervous over here yeah
he moves his hand kind of rubs his hand
then he brings it back and then he grabs
his hand again yeah the android is
getting very or no he's he's a droid
what is he yeah he's a humanoid what is
what is he's a he's a hybrid i mean you
know
this could be like bicentennial man kind
of situation where he's a robot and then
they put fake skin over him so he's kind
of so this is probably technology that
um someone invented elon bought it and
is taking credit for it yeah probably
yeah okay well let's let's continue to
watch what the
what the robotic um
jared kushner how he responds here to
the almost the almost journalistic
question from ducey
item today from maggie haberman and some
of the other reporters that apparently
there were 300 classified documents
mar-a-lago over the last what do you
make of that [ __ ]
you know they think they've gotten them
all by now
why would the former president have that
many classified things there we go
so so i'm not familiar with what exactly
the contents were and but what i'll just
say from my personal experience is you
think you think that's pre-programmed
that answer yeah yeah yeah
if like if you're programmed into the
area if you asked about why the
documents are there or did you know
about the documents it's like
it's just a conditional statement like
if this is the question or related to
these talking points right here answer
this i know else answer this thing about
that i am not familiar with what the
story you are speaking of the documents
at mar-a-lago were stored in the
basement very securely under
guard of secret service there was a lock
on the door it was a padlock and it is
very very spectacular bad luck let's
listen is that
again in the campaign in the transition
we had a very innocent meeting with uh
the russian ambassador and then you know
four months later you're reading that
the intel agencies are leaking to the
washington post that we requested this
secret back channel and then the new
york times and cnn go crazy for a
weekend accusing us of treason and then
it turns out such a thing never really
happened and so you know i i find it
funny that he's trying to compare
something that happened to him because
jared kushner i am very sure in this
moment
jared kushner and any um ivanka trump
they're actually they actually have
nothing to do with this classified
documents case yeah and and i i like
they're they're they have not touched
these things they were not privy in the
room when these things were i mean this
is this is just bad timing right all
around like obviously he had i didn't
know he was releasing a memoir until
just the other day when ivanka was like
right also ivanka used the same text
messaging uh database the listserv to
then send out a message to people that i
have on my burner phone that says hey my
husband just released a book and then
jared kushner was like hey everyone it's
jared i released my memoir
now i don't know how long this has been
in the works and and if it was like well
it had to be more than just a couple
well no no totally but i didn't like i
hadn't seen any sort of advertising or
marketing for it online or anyone talk
about it so what i'm saying is like i
know that they they had a date where
they're like this is the day we're gonna
release the book or the memoir so i
don't know
uh how far in advance that they knew and
they set the date and it was like boom
it is set in stone and we will do that
is when we have to do it and i don't
know if they're like oh [ __ ] like it
drops and they're like a week or two
weeks out
and they're like okay well we either
just go with it now
while people are talking about it maybe
people want to buy the book to learn
more to see if there's like any sort of
juicy like gossip in there or whatever
or
they're like ah [ __ ] like
it's it's too late we can't not release
it right we have to release it because
we set these dates and all the suppliers
and publishers and all these things
already have this date in mind and
everything's already been created so we
have to go forward with it so i don't
know man it could be either way but but
i feel i feel like the timing for sure
but i feel like though that that jared
kushner even by his a the ai standards
of his of his smile and his the shitty
grin on his face i believe that jared
kushner is very confident that his
fingerprints are not on these documents
yeah and that's why they're like look i
i this is his baby he's the one who did
these crimes after he became president
and that's why jared kushner talks about
[ __ ] that happened when the guy was
president he's like oh those crimes when
he was president oh those are that's a
completely different story but these
crimes i don't know what you're talking
about no idea i have no idea about that
gazillions of dollars that i took from
saudis because someone may have wink
floated a picture to them of documents
let's listen
i just think you have to be very careful
with what you read and obviously just
wait for the facts to develop but i mean
there's been so many things that have
been hyperventilated about over the last
years that turn out to be nothing and
that's again why i wrote this book was i
wanted people to really understand what
it was like to be living through that
when you know you living is he i mean
you know if you're not actually human
yeah if you're a robot are you living
through stuff yeah you just don't have
to use language that relates to an
actual human being that's part of the ai
i guess right to humanize himself let's
finish
you've done nothing wrong you're there
trying to get good things done and you
know people are out there you know
accusing you of all these crazy things
and you have to prove that those things
didn't happen so here's here's where
ducey could really do his job and these
three people sitting on this couch at
fox and friends could do the thing
called um now what the hell's that word
journalism
but they just
decided that juicy went a little too far
and the ai robot here
gave the right answer let's listen right
and no they didn't and it almost took
you down and
knowing that you were innocent you gave
all your time and all those interviews
and still had to wonder at the process
oh my god
oh my god you're talking about i was
like and you you are you you are into
the victim
you were the one who was targeted right
right like like i think jody i think was
asking this question jody was asking
this question earlier it's the ai robot
apparently who was a victim on fox and
friends right he's totally but the
ability that that brian kill me jumps in
because remember brian kilmeade is also
the one who was texting mark meadows on
january 6 about donald trump and how
they need to [ __ ] get this [ __ ] under
control right the fact that there was a
fox correspondent anchor whatever you
want to call them not journalists but
someone that they were that was texting
the chief of staff to donald trump on
january 6th while the [ __ ] was going
down
is little suss so the fact that brian's
like oh and and and and
and you yeah and that you and the thing
and that are here and you're you are the
victim here they came after you
and you
are still here today to tell your story
which is also funny i saw someone i
think was minus margie mentioned she
said it's funny how the author in quotes
says be careful what you read
while also on tour talking about the
book about uh pimping something that
you're supposed to read well fox news is
having a really rough time they're
having a really rough time and i don't
blame them and laura ingraham here miss
miss nazi herself explains why they're
having a rough time but you shouldn't
fret you shouldn't fret gabe you
shouldn't fret over how miserable
that that these candidates are that they
have to vote for you should just go vote
for him so that she can be a fascist
leader in the fascist regime
just go vote for these clowns and these
in these lunatics please please please
let's listen
so instead of complaining about our
candidates they're kind of being
wishy-washy on them we should recognize
that this group is actually great
[Music]
i mean if you're looking to make a
crudite maybe they are
nah no they don't even know how to make
a crew today yeah at this point they
don't even know what a veggie tree is
they don't even know how to make a
veggie tray laura but let's finish how
she justifies these clowns our nominees
with a few exceptions like colorado are
political newcomers they haven't had a
lot of experience but that's okay
they're out there fighting for the
average person they should be respected
for getting in the ring
she says
she says with colorado as an exception
she's talking about lauren bober right
because lauren bobert is running for
re-election
uh
this fall right during the midterms
right now she's trying to make that
she's trying to say that oh you know the
republicans are people that are actually
fighting for then tell me why
most if not all of the constituents and
you know okay we'll say not all but most
a majority of people have come forward
and expressed their
their uh
frustration
marjorie taylor green her district the
people she represents she doesn't
represent
they've they've come forward there was
an expose that was a few months ago last
year i forget when that talked about how
the people of her district
said that lauren bobert was more
interested in the success and fame of
running as a representative than
actually doing her job as a
representative
these people do not like lauren bobert
you know she unfortunately won her
primary but that's not to say that she
will win the midterm right right
so i think more and more people are kind
of waking up on both sides because
we're seeing the grip that's happening
and some people are beginning to realize
what's really happening and how they're
being played a fool in this whole thing
well here is one of the man of the
people that laura's talking about have
you followed this account wagner's
wagner's uh i haven't oh my
i think
am i want to
i i i want to i want to think that this
account was created before this whole
thing went down but it could be wrong i
i don't know but this this account is
hilarious and they're doing such a great
job of
absolutely destroying they found out it
was actually fetterman's campaign that
would be hilarious if it's if it if it's
you know what be better if it's like dr
oz's kid or his wife or something oh
yeah but it says flashback remember when
doc hollywood recreated pennsylvania's
signature breakfast gabe what do you
think the signature breakfast is of
pennsylvania here
that doctor
under dr oz that he says yeah what what
do you think i i
i want to believe it's um
it's caviar
on a
on a on a ritz cracker
with you mean dolphin fetuses yeah yeah
yeah
dolphin fetus i wanna i wanna believe
it's something that is so out of touch
like you're like oh what is for
breakfast oh as staple is like sausage
and eggs what would you say if you
because you're not from pennsylvania
have you been to pennsylvania before no
never been i i'm i i think i've been to
pennsylvania for a moment but
what would you imagine that folks in
pennsylvania would that would be their
staple breakfast i mean to me it's
probably like hotcakes or
are a big bowl of cereal or our
doughnuts i wanna i wanna think that
like pennsylvania being blue collar
right being
being the cool the lunchbox steak right
i to think that a breakfast would be
like
sausage hot links right
like maybe maybe a bratwurst kind of
thing pieces of eggs
baby french toast probably not scrambled
i think they're probably like maybe
maybe they're over easily breezy right
over easy uh and maybe some hash browns
right maybe yeah i don't know like
really crispy hash brown yeah with a lot
of salt pepper and butter on those
[ __ ] right i have no idea i
just like to think that but here is what
dr oz claims and this tick tock
is the staple pennsylvania breakfast
this is kind of weird it's like he's
never been to pennsylvania before all
right first up these beautiful
strawberries okay strawberries okay
we're getting some ice cream now
blueberries
pomegranate okay
yep don't forget
[Music]
water coconut water
did he just
he put ice well you know what someone
might think hey he's going to put this
in a blender right he's done if you put
ice in there have you put coconut like
i'm like oh soften it up and then you
put ice in there and then frozen
my thought is
he's making a smoothie right that's what
i think but watch watch as he eats the
what you think is going to be a smoothie
[Music]
no
no
what are you serious look at his face
he's even confused
look at him now i feel like a champion
you're not even supposed to chew ice
it's bad for your teeth a doctor should
know that what does he do why the ice i
mean okay
so i'm not against strawberries
blueberries blackberries or pomegranates
not against that at all really not even
against the coconut water where why are
everything no i'm against coconut water
but that's fine well i i mean you know i
you know most people who eat out of a
bowl like this like a cereal would put
would put milk in with the way that i
thought he was going with this i thought
he was going to throw the fruit in and
then he was going to throw yogurt in
that seemed like the logical next step
no for this [ __ ] no what a dumbass does
he really think does he really think
that the folks in pennsylvania the
average folks that laura ingram is
talking about is going to look at this
video and go yeah that's exactly what i
would ever be like why i'm still so
confused about the ice like is he eating
is he eating the ice or is he using the
ice to keep it cool because if he's
using it to keep it cool weirdo and my
mind says he has too much fruit in there
and maybe he's do a smaller portion
well what is what i think because that's
a lot of sugar by the way i mean i mean
most reasonable people keep their fruit
like in the container in the in the
refrigerator yeah and you know like i've
got like right now i've got strawberries
and blueberries in a container right in
the fridge and and it's good to have you
know fresh fruits and vegetables but i
don't eat it on i who eats it on over
coconut
water and ice what the [ __ ] is this
let's finish this and see if it gets
weirder
champion
[Music]
all right first off oh yeah
at the end totally makes it weirder and
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] again i do
not understand what the [ __ ] the ice is
for
laura ingraham thinks that this guy
making this video oh my god understand
it just it just seemed like look you
were making a fruit bowl right like a
fruit salad that's what you made that's
that is exactly what you made right
there and then you threw in coconut
water weird and then you threw an ice
even weirder well here here is a real
american this is at a yankees game oh
yeah man not too far not too far away
from pa but lizzy baby watch what
happens now this guy
i might get around this kind of
breakfast lunch or dinner watch what
happens in this video because dr oz
needs to learn a thing or two here
[Music]
he's got a straw
he's poking it through a hot dog what
the hell yeah
wait for it
wait for it genius is about to happen
it's a hot dog straw
real men love genius
that's what that that's what the
commercials are but this right here
that's a that's a glizzy straw baby that
is a glizzy guzzler and for people who
don't know a glizzy is a hot dog uh
but the fact that this dude made i can
here's the thing i can understand
though gross i wouldn't do it i can
understand the combination wait you wait
wait you wouldn't drink beer out of a
hot dog give me a break i might hear it
there's nothing better that goes at
least
once i would drink beer out of a hot dog
but at the same time i would say
it is where would you picky about your
hot dog would you be picky about it was
it just like is it plain hot dog well i
mean it's a ballpark hot dog so i'm
saying like is it
is it plain like i don't have like
mustard and ketchup get that mustard and
ketchup
yeah dogs are going to be kosher dogs
right so you know they're all good but
it's you know it's
got that good those sodium phosphates
whatever the [ __ ] is in there like it's
good
all the good all the good
hot dogs are great i love hot dogs i was
super excited july 4th i was like oh
great i get to have a hot dog this
weekend i don't have them pretty much
anytime unless i do go to a ballgame at
the dodger stadium but this is one of
those things where i have to say
it is weird i would try it at least once
at least once right here's the defense
here's the defense i'll make okay but
it's
it's it's the same reason that i'd be
like oh look let me have some like
peanuts with some beer like it's salty
like that type of but here's the silver
i feel it works let me let me let me
give you a good explanation of this okay
buns hot dog buns do not have beer value
all right but beer has hot dog bun value
that that is the key here when you take
a hot dog out of the bun
and speaking of hot dogs out of the bun
did you see this picture
oh my god that's the one i'm talking
about this is
i can't tell if the suit is too tight
or this is men and black type [ __ ] this
is one black type [ __ ] it i mean i i
yesterday i i literally just put in
quotes i said hello human i mean it's
what the hell is this
did they make him stand like this were
they like i don't know what is this
what's the uh what's the character oh
man i'm gonna blank on this maybe
someone in the chat knows it's like a
it's a dude with like a block face
and he's it's kind of like a ken doll
but
like it's not [ __ ] man this is really
definitely this is definitely not a
kindle no no no it's no definitely not
like it's like a florida ken you know
like florida man kendall oh my god
i gotta get this off the screen it's but
the the arms the arms like lift them up
a little bit higher and you've got
frankenstein's monster you know
it's
it's kind of weird that he was standing
like that for a picture i was surprised
he wasn't really trying to lean forward
like lean way but also it's not just him
on stage it's the i forget who else was
on stage with him
but they both look super [ __ ] awkward
on stage they're just looking out like
ha ha ha ha
like that's the type of vibe i'm getting
from that those two in that moment like
why are the arms lifted ever so slightly
why is the jacket so tight you can't
make this [ __ ] up why do you feel like
you are not normal a human it's almost
like you know one of them uh dolls that
you make stand up on a stick that's
right oh yeah well like the yeah yeah i
know yeah
yeah
yeah speaking of speaking of stuff that
doesn't make sense have you seen this
video of wendy rogers trying to explain
how to commit voter fraud have you seen
this
uh no i have nothing this is really
weird because she apparently thinks if
you have your own ballot you're
committing
identity theft or some [ __ ] i don't i
can't understand rogers is [ __ ] crazy
look i asked the question is it just me
are these people getting dumber because
it's just it's getting dumber and dumber
every time this happens now i have to
admit this is at mike lindell's little i
don't know whatever the hell this um
this great meeting is but the moment of
truth summit right the moment [ __ ]
the moment of [ __ ] but if you look
behind this is at the summit and it's
going on actively this isn't like before
the event look how many chairs there are
that have nobody in them it's not
surprising full house it is a full house
packed there's tens of people in here um
let's listen to what how wendy rogers
describes
to commit your own identity theft and
voter fraud i'm not sure exactly what
she's talking about but let's listen
refrain from using the mail right uh to
physically vote uh with your ballot but
here is also okay so um oh yeah they
said yeah this context they've been
saying this whole weekend don't
don't do mail-in ballots whatever you do
don't request one don't get one don't do
mail about which is hilarious because i
actually think the republican party is
going to lose like two or three percent
by these people just screaming and
yelling how much mail and ballots are
fraud and how people will take your vote
and [ __ ] like this because people aren't
gonna end up voting a lot of times
that's
part of their core constituent that's
the only way that they can actually vote
right because a lot of them can't get
out of the house to go vote because a
lot of them frankly are elderly and
that's how a lot of
disability whatever it might be these
people can't come out of the military
people who are
people who are traveling out of state
who are going to be gone during that
period i mean there's so many reasons
why a person would have a member this is
also the party well i mean they're no
longer the that party but the
republicans are the people that actually
advocated for mail-in ballots years ago
well because because their core
constituency that's that's how they
voted but let's listen to wendy rogers
if what you should do if you do request
one or you should request one because
she's trying to spin this because they
know they [ __ ] up here over the
weekend
making people not get male and ballots
let's listen refinement to that and it
is what i will do
when you receive your mailed in ballot
don't open it
i i vote by mail 76 percent of arizonans
vote by mail
the point is when you receive it
okay so she votes by mail and she just
said i don't know quarters of the state
votes by mail
well but but here's the thing is she
said i vote by mail but she's telling
other people don't know how the [ __ ] are
you going to vote if you don't open this
thing right if you don't believe
in vote by mail right mail in ballots
then why are you yourself
voting i don't be a mail-in ballot i
have no idea but the fact that she said
it out loud within the same breath of
like do not
vote with mail-in ballot do not open it
now i i vote by mail and i totally 76 of
arizonians do maybe maybe she's gonna
explain to us gabe how to vote on that
mail-in ballot
without opening it maybe it's like a a
trick that donald trump does when he
declassifies documents they just wave
their hands and go they think that they
think like some sort of telekinetic
transfer of power and vote they just
think they're like it's digital it's
digital gabe it's digital and then they
do it it's digital on a piece of paper
let's listen okay do not open it
carry it with you in your
back pocket to the poll
okay so you're supposed to get your
ballot god jesus don't don't don't gay
don't vote on that ballot
make sure to go to the poll with that
ballot and specifically don't put it in
your purse not in your backpack not in
the front pocket specifically
in the back pocket let's listen let's
hear the instructions because i'm sure
they're riveting
wait in line you may have to wait
several hours
because of your dumbasses yeah you may
have to wait a long time because you
people have made it to where everyone
has to wait in line to vote okay so
there's the next step to wait in line
for several hours because republicans
don't want you to vote like when you
rogers let's listen on election day yeah
and then when you show up
you say i'm here to vote and if they say
to you brian glenn
you voted that's not what they're going
to say
we're going to say you are they already
they what they're going to say is
we show that you already have a ballot
that's what normally happens and what do
they even say that though because like
in california we we get automatically
opt-in for for mail-in votes ballots
right and i went over to my polling
station my polling center uh for our the
primaries we had
uh the most recent election that we had
here in in la and nobody told me that oh
you already got it
right well they just checked they're
like all right great you confirmed each
state's a little different that's why
wendy rogers is way off the map here
because every state's different right
every state's different about
provisional balance as well
and and she's gonna she's gonna talk
about that here in a second about a
provisional battle let's listen
and you know that you didn't because
your ballot is in your hip pocket
no no back pocket she is totally mixing
this up yeah also his response goes wow
wow wow this is [ __ ]
mind-blowing stuff right now
let's listen then they will laugh for
you
did you see him did you see him look at
the camera like are we going to cut to a
break here because she's somebody saved
me i don't know what's going on watch
this watch this look that he gives to
the to the producer because there's a
producer standing there behind the
camera he's hoping they'll cut
and watch it's in your hip pocket
then they will offer you
he's like please
please cut this off
come on turn the feed off
wait wait for it this is great this is
fantastic what she says
a provisional ballot yeah a provisional
so now you'll have the one in your hip
pocket right plus the provisional ballot
that they've offered you uh-huh
yes you say stand by for a second you
pull out your phone and you call
the sheriff
okay so now
now what you do gabe because you have
two illegal ballots obviously because
there's no such thing as a legal ballot
anymore now that they have given you
possession of two illegal balance you
call the sheriff why would the [ __ ]
would you call the sheriff if they give
you a provisional ballot i don't know
figure this out like i've voted
i've had provisional ballots where i've
shown up to the polling places and
they're like oh this isn't your spot but
you can do provisional so you can vote
here and we will send it in and it'll be
right and then you have to well right
and you have to do certain things to
make your provisional ballot count a lot
of times right depending on the election
depending on the state there's things
you have to do because sometimes those
ballots have to cure it's almost like
there are certain procedures and
protocols that you follow to make sure
that no one could just throw in a
[ __ ] random ballot right
wendy rogers wants the sheriff to come
like that's the that is our best
use of resources we're going to call in
the sheriff like look
law enforcement is already flawed enough
but if you're going to waste the time to
call them in to say we need you to
double check it's like they're not
qualified to go over [ __ ] ballots how
would they know whether one is real or
not real or like
deciphering between
oh you have a mail-in ballot but you
came in to vote in person so what's the
crime well here there is no crime here's
the thing here's the thing just as you
think that these people cannot get
dumber and this clip cannot get dumber
oh baby
these last these last six seconds are
some dumb ass [ __ ] listen to what she
says
and you say
there is an identity theft issue i need
to report refrain
wait sorry did she is the i want to know
who said the sheriff said that no no
you're supposed to say that to the
sheriff when you call there's an
identity theft right identity like
someone someone stole her identity gabe
yeah like you know i don't know
so
she
takes the ballot which has been sealed
and shows up to vote in person
no one
would be able yep you got me to vote in
your name
it's because you have to show
identification you have to go through
this thing oh yeah you're so and so
sanchez got you boom you confirm you
live with this dress let me see your
your license or you know uh if i have
the ballot you know you can show that
too i guess but like it's one of those
things that it's it doesn't make any
sense
nope not at all at all just like this
guy doesn't make any sense at all none
of these things this this [ __ ]
breakfast in pennsylvania
the ballots
it's all [ __ ] i'm sure eric trump you
know the son of gary busey here is gonna
say something real smart oh it's it's
it's it's groundbreaking here it's
groundbreaking let's listen
to this 26 seconds of gold i'm telling
you even the energy i mean i was on a
flight this morning the energy on that
flight wait wait wait i gotta get the
sound i got to get the sound up here
because this is important this sounds
like another dumb [ __ ] lie this
sounds this sounds like we're gonna walk
into another story that sounds just like
when eric trump said oh my wife laura
and i were at a dinner and these couple
next to us were fighting over who was
gonna pay for our dinner
no one [ __ ] did that
no one
ever fought over who's gonna pay for
your [ __ ] meal well you and your wife
stole millions of dollars from a kid's
charity a dog charity you guys are
[ __ ] terrible people awful people no
one is ever
ever in the history of time has ever
said
i will i'm willing to fight over who's
gonna pay for eric and laura trump's
meal well one apparently they need their
meal paid for because they can't even
afford to take private flights anymore
he's got a flight coach they're telling
us what's happening you guys you've got
don jr who's complaining about gas
prices them talking about you got eric
trump who's complaining about paying for
dinner and also fine coach they're
[ __ ] broke let's listen i'm telling
you even the energy i mean i was on a
flight this morning the energy on that
flight everybody came up with to me
sorry what these people are doing to
your family your father has to go out
there you have our vote you have our
entire families though you've got our
type everyone everyone happened they did
not have one on the flight no one is
telling him on the flight hey i'm so
sorry what's happening your dad right
now and if they were no one is offering
up their [ __ ] money to pay for their
meal these are people again that are
also like oh man you know the people
that are the same people that are
complaining
about inflation and the prices of this
and that and not being able to afford
things i highly doubt those people
though i could be i could be corrected
because hey no i mean
trump does live uh does like the you
know the uneducated so who knows right
but i
i call [ __ ] on on this story on
every story that eric trump has told
especially when when he went on to sean
hannity and said he was going to release
the cctv footage [ __ ] no he won't
because that shit's going to show in 4k
that they've been lying this whole time
and they stole and they purposely hid
and they withheld documents
he's never going to do it he's lies
about he just lies about everything well
speaking of uh crimes and breaking news
it looks like just in the last few hours
a federal jury has convicted two men of
conspiring and to kidnap the michigan
governor whitmer in a plot prosecutors
describe as rallying cry for the u.s
civil war by anti-government extremists
these two uh
sounds about white with these two um but
apparently the two the two gentlemen the
two mogalodites the two delusional
brain dead idiots who thought it was a
good idea to plot to kidnap the governor
uh for their plot in the civil war
have now been convicted by a federal
grand jury and i'm sure that the judge
whoever it is who sentenced these these
two boneheads is not going to go easy on
them so there's there's some breaking
news there in the uh
in the trial
of the plot to kill a governor of
michigan
and of course it's governor whitmer
because uh she was an enemy of trump and
he kind of called her out on social
media you remember at the time during
the 2020 election
um and and it just kind of went on and
they decided that it was a good idea to
kidnap her yeah oh now now he's in a big
big they're in big big trouble because
they've been
found guilty by a federal jury
in court uh oh it's like who thought
like who who who would have thought
that donald trump has an enemy and i put
that in quotes because like you know
there are no world enemies here well
everyone has his name right right it's
someone that he trump has decided is the
person that is attacking them they are
the victim right or he's the victim and
so
trump goes after these people
and
by proxy
his supporters then say you're the enemy
you're the villain and i have to go
after you and then you have these
[ __ ] crazy people who decide to plot
a [ __ ]
uh kidnapping right because like oh
you're you're you're you know you're
you're an enemy donald trump said you
were a bad person they take what he says
literally
his supporters his his pain his paid
supporters
his fans his cult
they will take what donald trump says
literally despite the fact that trump
was like oh i was he was tongue-in-cheek
he was being sarcastic this and that is
like was he
or was he he being serious and then now
that people are calling him out he's
saying oh he was being sarcastic but the
people that hear him
take care literally trying to kidnap
governors of states uh gabriel just like
just like when he says on january 6th
we're going to go there and you want to
fight you know fight like hell right you
want to show your representative you
know
what you want them to know right hang
mike pence hang mike pence listen we're
out of time today thanks for sticking
around to the whole show
uh i want to i didn't even realize we
went over i want to give i want to give
the uh uh one more shout out to jody
over on facebook everyone if you can
hear me go follow jody over on facebook
um
here's jody's handle jody nelson
robertson and jody again i'm sorry i
mixed up your comment but i glad you
asked the question and we can answer the
question
again she's a she's a fighter in
democracy and we need more of those we
need all of you to be fighters in
democracy so if you're in florida new
york or oklahoma today make sure you
fight for your democracy and engage in
your democracy by using the power of
your ballot and getting out and voting
if you haven't already in those states
do the things that you should do
and do democracy if you want to support
pro-democracy speech you can do it right
here on the tony michaels podcast the
link is at the bottom
support.tonymichaelspad.com
or you can use the qr code there in the
corner and we appreciate all the support
that we've been given and the audience
oh my gosh you guys have been a great
audience make sure to subscribe to
youtube that helps us out as well if you
you can't give to free speech support it
by subscribing liking sharing the link
with your friends go to twitter and
follow us at tonymichaelspod that also
helps there to get us the message around
and don't forget to download every
single episode monday through friday
we are live noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific on youtube twitter twitch and
simulcasting from the facebook page of
midas touch but you can download every
episode on apple spotify google your
favorite directory while you're there
leave us a great review it helps us out
thanks for all the support everyone
until tomorrow same time same place
same democracy
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking